la directrice des ressources humaines
france voulait une arrivée discrète mais
doit finalement passer par la grande
porte
escorté par des grévistes sans répondre
à la moindre question
le site connaît krainz de saint vallier
spécialisée dans la fabrication de
stickers des grues conçu pour charger et
décharger des conteneurs et qui emploie
cent quarante deux personnes
la direction souhaite supprimer 115
postes liés à la production pour des
motifs économiques
le site ne serait plus viable un coup
dur pour les salariés en espère
retrouver du travail derrière avoir la
possibilité d'être classé surtout l'âge
et la clim 54 ans il reste des années à
faire quand même ça fait quand même 14
ans bientôt kullas moi comme j'ai dit je
pensais finir ma carrière ici
même si et les carrières longues sont
rares à l'heure actuelle voilà je veux
dire ça fait un peu mal mobilisés sur
place
les élus des communes voisines
soutiennent le mouvement est aussi
s'insurge de la fermeture du site alors
que l'entreprise prospère
ça n'a pas de sens si ce n'est que de
vouloir neutraliser sa concurrence au
niveau en niveau n'est au niveau mondial
moi je suis pas là pour anticiper mais
pour dire travaillons ensemble les
salariés une direction c'est le voulez
bien est les élus locaux pour
réindustraliser cite l'avocat des
salariés prévoit de porter deux
injonction auprès de la direction et une
procédure devant le tribunal judiciaire
il dénonce un détournement de la loi
florange la direction ici estime
qu'elles ne ferment pas un établissement
parce qu'elle laisse 26 personnes sur
place c'est un détournement de la loi
florange pour dispenser l'entreprise de
chercher un repreneur
le préfet de saône-et-loire à condamner
publiquement cette décision et dénonce
une fermeture qui n'obéit à aucune
logique industrielle
contactée la direction n'a pas souhaité
répondre à nos questions